meanwhile the Trump administration is
putting new pressure on so-called
sanctuary cities the Department of
Justice is threatening to subpoena
records in nearly two dozen states and
cities if they don't comply with the
demands of immigration and customs
enforcement Jeff Pegues is in Washington
with the intensifying showdown Jeff good
morning well good morning this standoff
is escalating the Justice Department
believes that these cities and states
are defying federal law but many of the
23 jurisdictions fired back yesterday
arguing that the Trump administration's
actions are unamerican deportations have
increased by 37 percent under the Trump
administration's crackdown on illegal
immigration that is included sparring
with local law enforcement who protect
illegal immigrants immigrant communities
I'm sure they'd much rather have my
officers in a County Jail than in their
neighborhoods the acting director of ice
Thomas Holman said by failing to
cooperate sanctuary cities do more harm
than good
they actually put the immigrant
community a risk by releasing public
safety trust back in those very
communities the DOJ is demanding
documents on whether local law
enforcement agencies are illegally
withholding information from u.s.
immigration authorities cities and
states such as California Illinois in
Oregon as well as New York City Los
Angeles and Chicago received subpoena
threats I know so much about being a
mayor in response to the threat mayors
from some of those cities boycotted a
meeting with President Trump at the
White House the mayors who choose to
boycott this event have put the needs of
criminal illegal immigrants over
law-abiding Americans Oakland Mayor
Libby Schaaf says roughly a third of her
city's population are immigrants
children afraid that their parents will
not come home from work she believes the
Justice Department's actions are only
increasing tensions between ice and her
constituents and she's vowing to take a
stand if I have to go to jail I would be
proud as an American and as an Oakland
er to do that
acting director Holman would not discuss
any planned operations for California
but he did acknowledge that the state
will see more a lot more immigration
officers and he says that is a direct
response to the states and cities
they're not cooperating with the feds
Dora really interesting Jeff thank you
so much